[Music]
but i would follow my passion i mean
whatever turned you on
you know i uh
uh i found i was lucky i found something
early that that turned me on but but uh
you don't want to take a job just for
the money you don't want to take a job
for an organization that you really
don't feel good about or work for people
that you don't feel good about you you
really want to be excited when you get
out of bed every morning it won't
necessarily be the job that you have 10
years later
but you'll be learning so much as you go
along and check what i was earning
because i just knew it was the right
thing to be
to be doing so i would i would i would
follow follow your passion and that's
one of the things you guys will find
that you have passions and having a
passion is a gift i think we all have
passions and you don't get to
choose them they pick you but you have
to be alert to them you have to be
looking for them and when you find your
passion it's a fantastic gift for you
because it gives you direction it gives
you purpose
uh you can have a job or you can have a
career or you can have a calling and the
best thing is to have a calling and if
you find your passion you'll have that
and all your work won't feel like work
to you
do you think you never know exactly you
know you don't choose your passions your
passions choose you
how you how they are formed you're never
completely sure but i do think you get
imprinted somehow early on with certain
things you just get excited about them
and because you're excited you pay more
attention and they grow
and that's space is like that for me i
watched neil armstrong step under the
moon when i was five
people say
you you have to have a lot of passion
for what you're doing and it's totally
true and the reason is
is because it's so hard that if you
don't any rational person would give up
it's really hard and you have to do it
over a sustained period of time so if
you don't love it if you're not having
fun doing it you don't really love it
you're going to give up and that's what
happens to most people actually if you
really look at
at the ones that
ended up you know being successful
unquote in the eyes of society and the
ones that didn't oftentimes it's
the ones that are successful loved what
they did so they could persevere
when you know when it got really tough
and and the ones that
didn't love it quit
because they're sane
right who would want to put up with this
stuff if you don't love it so it's a lot
of hard work and and it's a lot of
worrying constantly and
if you don't love it
you're going to fail so you got to love
it you got to have passion
when i say i saw none of this coming
when i first touched down in the state
of california 27 years ago
the only thing that got me from there to
here
other than luck was a deep passion for
technology and an open mind
so take the time to find the thing that
excites you more than anything else in
the world
not the thing your parents want you to
do
or the thing that all your friends are
doing
or that society expects of you
people
listening to this show know know what
their passion is and um
and they may it could be a hobby it
could be
um you know they could love reading they
could love playing tennis they could
they'll have passions
um and if you have a passion uh
it makes sense to spend a lot of your
life in involved in that passion
and quite often you can turn your
passion
into a business you can see
that maybe there's some aspect of your
passion that people are not doing that
well and um and
you know you can say screw it you know i
i could i could i could do it better um
and i think all you know if you spend
your life with your eyes open looking
for
looking for things that frustrate you
looking for a gap gaps in the market um
that's all the business is is it's
fulfilling that you know filling in a
gap and doing it better than it's been
done by anybody else um
and
uh and
and you know if people who don't have
closed minds will most likely find find
that or find those opportunities
now i suspect there will be
a hundred people who will have come up
with that idea before you um
but those hundred people
um you know won't have had the courage
just to go and do something about it so
um you know so those few people who just
say right you know that i'm going to
give it a go
um that and often end up
you know being being successful
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here